[Music]
I'm feeling like a lot of people are
feeling helpless lately with non-stop
bad news and even EDD has reduced our
resistance our resistance by our
capacity for nuance and for empathy you
know if you are moving from moment to
moment and avoiding a pause consider
that neurologists tell you that the
pause is where the memory is becomes
entrenched and it's where emotion
synthesized after the event in the pause
you you you if you don't go down you
can't feel the going up again so in this
era where every pause is filled with
checking your phone when porn when you
skip to the shot you know from
shot to comes out to shots you know
and if there's no pause the orgasm is
feels like nothing and the same with
with joy the same with sadness if you
never stop you go you can never feel
fully so my goal at times is to create
pauses more than create the actual thing
between the pauses which some would call
things or events or words or or just
sounds in this case with the podcast I
was very careful like this needs to be
24 more frames of pause I used the film
term because there's 20 24 frames per
second I said the audience is not
feeling it because they don't have
enough time to pause so I'm the the art
of the pauses what I'm
now anthem is the name of our series
every season will be a different musical
in probably ten episodes and our first
season is called homunculus
my character Qian is down-and-out failed
writer in a trailer park in the Midwest
whose run out of insurance and he's got
a brain tumor and the tumor one of the
names of a kind of tumor has is
homunculus which is Latin for little man
and the tumor becomes a character but my
characters online he's doing an
app-based telethon to crowdfund his
treatment this piece was really more
about me it's really more of an
alternative autobiography the character
is became really me
if I never left my small town what would
I be like so I wrote it as a TV series
it was too weird for Hollywood
you know the resting pitch faces and you
know desks across LA we're saying no and
a company called topic studio said yes
in New York to it as a podcast it was an
old form that is being rebooted for
today
you know audio theatre has always been a
traditional part of radio and has sort
of been forgotten and except for some
comedy let's say but this I really
wanted something more like cinema of the
mind obviously it's much cheaper though
we may be one of the more expensive
podcasts ever made because of the
density of it and it's really something
that we want to we want to push the
podcast form into a more you know
complex nuanced dense fictional place
I'm used to theatre I'm used to two
novels you know the words and the music
evoke images you
if sometimes a thousand words is better
than a picture - otherwise we wouldn't
have just I have skiing Nabokov and you
know being lasting so long I'm a word
person you know I'm a music person but I
love words you know when people say
films shouldn't shouldn't be too wordy
and you know it's like why not you know
éric rohmer that so many great
filmmakers their word based so in our
case when there is an image that's
important to see for our listeners to
envision we have characters that
describe them in a poetic way which is
of course the ancient form of prose in
poetry they evoke images and evoke other
feelings and other senses I think the
one of the reasons podcasts are very
popular right now because it's a bit of
counterintuitive in this day and age of
of peak sensory overload is that people
are finding one sense is just fine thank
you very much we're overloaded I wrote
it all as a theater piece first and then
wrote it as a all as a television series
and then adapted it for podcast so I've
had a lot of time to parse it to do
readings to edit the hell out of it and
it's that kind of time is really needed
for something this dense I think one of
the reasons a lot of you don't get you
know as many wonder Kent's on youtube in
a narrative way is because it requires a
lot of skills it's not just music or
just visuals or just acting or just
comedy it's all of those things
including the talents of production
which is oh my god how do you get it
onto screen or on to a camera and that
requires patience it's an ad D world a
lot of young people patience
was the strong suit
in fact the spontaneous you know shoot
myself for Instagram is you know the
main form format of the moment and that
doesn't always allow for the complexity
of a real narrative storytelling it
could it can make for something fun and
exciting and funny but the kind of stuff
the literary kind of stuff that I like
requires a lot of time and patience and
patience is not you know really
something that's honored anymore I find
in pop culture and certainly not in
politics lately so I'm a tortoise as
opposed to a hare and I like to you know
think it's ruined gather my thoughts and
and hammer away and sculpt it which is
what I've been doing for the last year
and a half
[Music]
you